[Music]
Einstein was convinced that there is one
big picture one way of looking at things
which actually makes sense of our world
but it has different elements okay so he
is as you all know a wonderful scientist
probably the best known scientist of
20th century and he deserves two
accolades and in many ways he's someone
who has worked hard to help us
understand how science functions but as
many of you will know Einstein was also
very interested in ethics and very
interested in religion let me give you a
quote from a from a lecture he gave
talking about the relationship of
science religion ethics here we go this
understand from a lecture of 1939
science he writes cannot create ends and
even less instill them in human beings
at most it can supply the means by which
to attain certain ends and the point is
trying to make here is that science is
great and it may help us inform our
ethical thinking but it doesn't give us
the answers again here's another quote
from that same lecture the scientific
method can teach us nothing beyond how
facts are related to and conditioned by
each other
the knowledge of what is does not open
the door directly to the knowledge of
what should be one may the clearest and
most complete knowledge of what is and
yet not be able to deduce from that what
should be the goal of our human
aspirations so what I'm saying is that
basic when he comes into his politics
and his ethics science might help a
little bit but really he's using a
different method night many of you will
know that Einstein was a very committed
socialist and in effect got his
socialist values not from science but in
effect from reflecting on what it meant
to be a human being especially with the
situation of 1930s in Nazi Germany as
many as you will know
was German and in effect had to leave
Germany because he was Jewish in 1929
29:33 and settled in united states so
here's my point
Einstein was absolutely convinced you
can be a scientist he was and you can be
a socialist he wants and saw these in
effect as being two aspects of his life
two bits of this bigger picture - like
so think about this he's a scientist
allowed to be a socialist or we don't
like socialism
is a scientist allowed to be a political
liberal or conservative I think the
answer has to be yes because science
doesn't lay down this is a way you've
got to be politically or ethically and
then we move on to the whole area of
religion this to me is really
interesting
Einstein took the view that religion
really is important heals he had his own
view what religion was it he did not
believe in a personal God he believed in
a God who was the mind behind this
universe and science could help you kind
away know something about this God and
it was really a fundamental motivation
for doing science but he didn't really
like his own Judit Jewish religion very
much or Christianity or anything
actually but he liked this idea that
being something deeply religious about
the way the world was and again that was
part of the way he was and Einstein for
example talks about his idea what God is
like listen to this I believe in
Spinoza's God who reveals himself in the
orderly of harmony of what exists or
again I believe in it I have a firm
belief in a superior mind that reveals
itself in the world of experience an
Einstein sold that as being important as
well and in fact he was saying this is
part of the picture it in effect gives
us a motivation for studying religion
studying science because a kind of way
opens up these deeper questions and for
Einstein that was really interesting and
important debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute
of Austin ideas her III TV
you